today the justice department arrested
Jack Douglas deshara in connection with
an investigation into alleged
unauthorized removal retention and
transmission of classified National
Defense information
Tashara is an employee of the United
States Air Force National Guard
FBI agents took to share into custody
earlier this afternoon without incident
he will have an initial appearance at
the U.S District Court for the District
of Massachusetts I want to thank the FBI
justice department prosecutors and our
colleagues at the Department of Defense
for their diligent work on this case
this investigation is ongoing we will
share more information at the
appropriate time thanks everyone